any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
so we talk about hype and i want to ask
you about artificial intelligence
the claim is that artificial
intelligence is going to
eventually produce you know artificial
galileo
and i've actually worked with since i
now have the text one million words of
his dialogue in printed form
now for the first time to make the
audiobook i am going to uh put it into
gpt3
and see if i can teach him qed or you
know
whatever but but just see what will come
out of it because i think it'll be
interesting
but my my assumption is that
just because uh computers can beat any
human at chess
it doesn't mean they can create the game
of chess in other words uh
they can't they can solve a rubik's cube
can they invent a rubik's cube
but in the essence of physics the note
the claim is that it's just a you know
max tag mark has written about this
you know it's just a matter of time
before we have artificial finemen
it doesn't matter whether the
information is processed by
carbon atoms in neurons and brains or by
some other kind of atoms in machines we
build ultimately
there's no law of physics saying that
we are the smartest kind of cork blobs
that can possibly exist
so the bigger question is is to me is
not
whether it's possible to blow away human
intelligence with machines but
just whether we will be smart enough to
figure out how to do it and hey
we just had the europe's conference
which is sort of like the
the ai rock concert of the year which
keeps
growing exponentially in size and
it's just quite mind-boggling how fast
this field is progressing i'm not you
know just a few years ago robots
couldn't walk properly
now today we have a viral video of
robots dancing in the new year at boston
dynamics
not long ago you know we didn't have
self-driving cars
now we have self-landing rockets thanks
to elon
and not long ago we didn't have machines
that could even beat us at the asian
board game of go
and now just the other week google deep
mind came out with the latest the mu
zero which not only crushes us to go
and chess and japanese chess shogi
but also in all the atari games from the
old times pretty much
without even being told the rules so
things are happening fast
do you know what einstein called the
happiest thought of his life not fantasy
but the happiest thought of his life
lawrence i i seem to remember it but
remind me as a no sense is that if you
were in free fall
you'd experience zero exactly yeah yeah
yeah gravity would be uh
he called that the hat now how can a
computer and that's what led to gr
you know in some sense um how can a
computer a know what
it feels to free fall b know what uh
know what happiness is in this context
and c how can they take that
intellectual leap
if you're just taking data from newton
and showed the perihelion of mercury
anomalously advances
how would you possibly get from that you
know lacunae
in the data to a new way of thinking
about a fundamental force so
those are my opinions what do you think
about i think i think you're being
short-sighted but i also think these
other people are being ridiculous
i mean first of all anytime you hear
people predict things about things we
don't know anything about
they call themselves futurists often
that's when those are people you
shouldn't listen to
um and almost invariably they miss the
important stuff
i mean we were supposed to be in flying
cars and you know when in the 1950s but
when they talked about 2000 but they
didn't talk about the internet
well first of all we don't even know
what intelligence is in some deep sense
but
but you're making the assumptions that
you know i can't input all of the
um the sensory uh
data input that you would feel in free
fall and and for me
i see no barriers ultimately
to what you would call it an artificial
consciousness but it's not
the problem with artificial intelligence
is not artificial in any sense
it's it's creating a an electronic
version of a system that arrives
haphazardly by biology
and and and biology did it very
effectively because it had a long time
to do it
um so i don't see any barriers to
ultimately
what you would call computers being
conscious i i ultimately
don't see computer finding is not the
way of putting it but what i i
am interested in a general artificial
intelligence in
in in those using those language which i
don't like
um precisely for the same reason i think
that feynman was
which is i would like to know
what an intelligent computer what
physics questions an intelligent
computer would find interesting
and there's not it's not at all clear to
me that they'd be the same questions
it's to me it's just like wanting to
know about an alien intelligence
i would love to have an alien
intelligence so i'd like to learn a lot
about what they've learned about the
world and how they think about it
because it would illuminate
presumably potentially a completely
different way of thinking about the
world than i'm used to
if we allow data to come in we will
discover something new
okay so the self-fulfilling prophecy is
if you don't search you will never find
and
on the other hand if we do search we
will find something
and i believe that within my lifetime
there is a chance
that we will get our hands on a
technological relic from another
civilization
and that would be amazing so i have
something to
wait for not the response of my
colleagues
not uh flattery from people around me
um rather allowing nature to give me
uh new knowledge by looking at it
and that's all and i don't need anything
more than that
so i don't see it as a say a threat in
that sense nor do i see it as a panacea
i see it i think in the long run is kind
of inevitable but not in any but i mean
long run i don't think
all ai is an area that's incredibly
hyped
you're absolutely right computers can
feed people at chess but they can't
but robots can't yet really effectively
fold laundry
um and and so um you know this notion of
you know around the corner
that's going to happen i think it's
ridiculous i find it fascinating that
plato
and others going back to plato and in
full circle
around the time that writing was first
invented
totally decried writing because they
said it would ruin storytelling
storytelling would be over because
people wouldn't have memories they
wouldn't be able to do this stuff and of
course it didn't happen
and as computational systems become more
capable in different areas
it will change things but i don't see
um i i guess i don't see the same beer i
think you're just
imposing the present on the future
who knows what the origins of creativity
is except it's making connections
at some level between disparate things
in some way i don't see any barrier
ultimately to a
computer with sufficient sent input from
a variety of things to be able to not
understand
what what it how happy it is to fall
in the absence of gravity that we feel
pain
in the everywhere we feel pain in the
brain
okay not the fingers not when not the
ones that are being burned it's in the
brain that it's created
and and it's and it's created because of
a whole bunch of biochemical reactions
that relate to sensory input
and i don't see that electrochemical
reactions or electrical reactions
related to similar sensory input can't
create the same
feelings in that artificial brain but
it's this fundamental physical
philosophical question which none of us
can ever really answer
which is how do i know that your pain is
the same as my pain how do i know that
you're green
even though i'm colorblind that your
green is the same as migraines
[Music]